and Kita's writing in who is your mentor
and also how do you find the mentor if
you don't have one that's a great great
point I think actually in terms of small
risks the key thing is generally you
want to attach yourself to someone whose
shares in vision is a disrupter but also
ideally we've got the experience of
having walked on your journey before so
you know they know where the bear traps
are but they know kind of where the
quick wins are all those sort of things
and they can really help you navigate
and manage the risks too you know the
pot of the pot of gold at the end of the
rainbow so I would say I've really been
lucky I've had lots of mentors but
they're both my formal mentors but I
love just informal mentors now I
encouraged in our company I say to
people all our colleagues you know
there's someone you really respect just
go and grab them in a hallway and say
look would you mind coming for a coffee
with me mentoring can be over a coffee
and a 30-minute conversation and I've
never known anybody with experience to
say no they always you know everybody
likes to help and everybody loves to
help the next generation I love going
out tomorrow I'm going with safe
foundation we're going out foodbanks
with kids and volunteering and we're
going to be out with teenagers and you
know what better way for me to spend
some time and honestly I think I think
again you've got to stop those voices in
your head telling you I can't ask that
person to be my mentor and I wouldn't
even use the word mentor just say
looking at some advice I've got massive
respect for you you've achieved a great
deal and I just welcome some advice I've
never known anybody to say no so I would
also say the other thing is you know
there's lots of people you need to go to
when you look at kind of the risk in
your business you'll say what are the
big risks is it a product risk is it you
know can I build a website can I visit
technology with and then once you've
identified there go and find the
you can kind of plug the gaps either in
your network on social media there's
tons of people out there who are
available well and social media you want
to make sure you know they're authentic
and they're not looking to kind of make
money or explore you so you've got to be
sensible there however then you can I'd
say this guy Evan
I'd say Evans one of my menses you know
Evan gives me advice he pings me you
know a little tweet he pings me an email
he tells me what we're doing okay he
says where we can do better I love that
I love that because it just keeps me
honest and I think what I'd say
therefore you should have a you
shouldn't spend all your day Piatt meant
it but there's key people that you
respect that can help you navigate the
risks and overcome them and you should
reach out to them and I guarantee that
they'll be there for you and they'll be
there to support you and sometimes you
know if they're really amazing people
you know and you grow your business you
get to 10 people 20 people and sometimes
you're gonna think about you know
investment downstream there'd be amazing
people to invest in your business as
well the only thing I would add is I
also benefit tremendously from
aspirational mentors you can learn a lot
from people who you will never meet and
so if you look at people who have done
what you want to do and and you know we
read their books
Steven recommended a number already Jeff
Bezos and a few other ones you can find
videos of them I do a lot of them on
this channel you can find aspirational
mentors in addition to traditional
mentors who you're going out and meeting
for coffee in having that one-on-one
relationship you can reach out to people
just by researching them and finding
their views and learn from someone who
has done like way more than somebody you
know way more than the then you thought
your expectations yourself might be and
that pushes you to want to be able to do
more so I would just couple those
together traditional mentorship plus the
aspirational mentorship to make your
dream team to help your your business be
successful
you